mon copain qu'est ce que tu fais ce que
tu fais moi c'est pas moi ce que je vais
faire du sport
j'en ai besoin pour me dépenser parce
que je veux pas rester à la maison
je peux presque même là mais s'est
classé alors j'ai ma carte d'identité si
vous voulez je vous la donne tout de
suite
restez chez vous c'est le message que
s'attache à faire passer ben et lassana
médiateurs de rue en cette période de
pandémie de kovy 19 la mairie de
nanterre tient à maintenir la présence
active de ses agents de tranquillité
publique
objectif sensibiliser la population
confinement et mesures de sécurité sont
nécessaires et savent que c'est
dangereux
ils avaient tous des téléphones on voit
même si vous voulez donc ils voient tous
les morts donc m'amener aurait dires
mêmes des gens qui sont avant tout
théorique antitrust a pris conscience
qu'il ya un réel danger et que c'est
fait pas n'importe quoi ce qui sera mis
en place depuis 2005
cette brigade est au coeur de la ville
ben et lassana investissent des lieux
publics repère des situations à risque
règle des conflits et neutralise
détention éducation scolarité
délinquance juvénile ou encore exclusion
sociale sur leur terrain d'action
nanterrien de naissance ben et lassana
jouissent d'une certaine légitimité
auprès des jeunes de la ville nous et
nous ont aidé un peu
enzo beaucoup causé aussi est aussi sûr
que ceux qui viennent nous voir conduire
de plus faire de vrai que les uniformes
bleus le rapport avec avec la population
c'est pas le même que celui de la police
comme annoncé c'est différent c'est
différent nous on vient on est des
frères on est une connaissent avec la
veste et sans veste
on est aussi du quartier 1 on est du
quartier d'ailleurs ce service il a été
créé aussi avec la majorité avec des
personnes vivantes dans le quartier de
nanterre dans les quartiers populaires
de nanterre si les choses peuvent
s'arranger de manière humaine comme cela
est écrit ci tranquillité manière
tranquille ça suffit la brigade de lutte
contre les incivilités est l'une des
fiertés de la mairie de nanterre qui on
lire dans ce combat pour renforcer le
lien social et le sentiment de sécurité
des habitants car à dos lourenço
directeur de la tranquillité publique
travaille depuis une douzaine d'années
au sein de cette escouade que patrick
jarry maire de nanterre s'attache à
maintenir sur le terrain aucun moment le
maire de nanterre n'a pensé à l'arrêter
nous non plus au contraire on a plutôt
tenté de l'intensifier on à l'aide d'un
certain nombre d'agents d'autres
services d'agent des sports par exemple
d'agents des services de jeunesse qui
viennent nous aider et épauler nos
équipes pour quadriller la ville et pour
pouvoir diffuser ce message auprès de la
population
malgré la pandémie ils sont 24 agents à
tous les jours arpenter les rues pour
rassurer les nanterriens on est là pour
vous dire faites attention à vous
n'oubliez pas votre masque légaux à et
l'alcool ok et les distances de sécurité
mais en fin de journée à les préserver
vous revoir